Hey, how's gun chapter in? What's
up? Not much done. Pretty good.
Do you mind if I ask you 67
questions? Yeah, go for it.
Alright, let's do this. Cool.
What project are you currently working on?
So we just launched the universe and
I'm working on some of the followup
releases we're going to do for that.
Awesome.
How would you describe the
culture at open AI? Super Cool.
I love everyone I work with here. Uh,
very open. Lots of good mentorship.
What was it like attending MIT as an
Undergrad? Really, really great. Uh,
MIT has a lot of cool sub communities.
They're all super creative.
You went to school at Nyu,
do you Miss New York City?
I think it was my friends there.
Um, but I don't miss the weather.
Favorite internship? Uh, Amazon, if
you could repeat one experience again,
what would it be?
I'd like to go back to Japan.
Why do you think deep learning
has gotten so popular recently?
It's really well for a lot of problems.
Um,
but I think people are sort of confusing
it for like the last big innovation,
but there's more to come. What is your
favorite operating system? Who Been Too
nice? If you could spend an evening
with one famous person, who would it be?
Michelle Obama. Do you play
any sports? I do rock climbing.
What time do you go to sleep?
Like midnight.
Most adventurous thing you've
ever done. What? Skydiving.
What's one source you use to
stay up to date in ml? Uh,
so Jack Clark who does PR for us has
this newsletter called import Ai.
It's great programming,
language of choice for machine learning.
Definitely pipeline.
Favorite professor. Let's go.
Josh Tenenbaum in MIT named
one person you really admire.
I'm also professor Fay.
Fay Lee.
She does a lot of AI and also
outreach neuroscience stuff.
How are you liking the bear? Yeah. Great.
There's a lot of cool communities here.
What drives you to be an engineer?
I really like building
things and especially the
things that I build can help
other people. What's the most
beautiful thing in the world?
Let's say it's helping out other people,
even if you don't agree with them or
if you're different from one another.
What's your favorite exercise?
Uh, I did Japanese Tyco drumming.
Favorite food? Croissants.
What's more fun?
Computer Science Theory or implementation?
I think implementation,
but you might think differently.
What website do you waste? Time.
I spent a lot of time on Facebook.
My friends read a lot of cool stuff there.
Last person you emailed. I emailed a
candidate in robotics that I met at nips.
You get an all expenses paid trip
to one city. Where do you go? Well,
never been to Africa. So maybe
Cape Town. Would you visit Mars?
Not unless it was cheap.
What's one thing you can't live without?
Um, my bicycle. What's one of
your favorite genres of music?
Spotify tells me that I listened
to a lot of ambient electronic.
So let's go with that. What's one
skill you wish you had better drawing.
What's the first thing you do when you
wake up? I hit snooze. What techs editor.
Do you use? Emacs but not
a holy war, I promise.
What open source library
do you really like? Uh,
I think really the requests in python
recently. It makes GDP super easy.
What's one of your favorite
movies? Uh, the original matrix.
What was a hard problem you recently
solved at open AI who were dealing with
some weird bugs when the environments
we're resetting and universe.
So trying to figure out why
that was going wrong was tough.
What inspired you to get
into machine learning?
I've always been really interested in
how humans think and the existence of be
sort of interesting biological,
cognitive agents.
But what if you could build one yourself?
What was the first program you ever made?
Um,
first interesting program I ever made
was to figure out how to spell your name
using a chemical elements. Symbols.
Whoa. What's one book you really liked?
Um, man, a wizard of
Earthsea are still, go ahead.
What's a big misconception about,
you don't realize I was born in Australia.
What's one thing that excites
you? The future? I mean,
who knows how it's gonna turn out
best advice you've ever received.
Someone pointed out that I've already
got a lot of the things that I want,
so I should stop being
so stressed out about it.
What's the bravest thing you've ever done?
Quitting Grad school with? Super tough.
I had sort of planned the trajectory
for my life and having to change that
really hard. What's one piece of advice
you'd give yourself 10 years ago?
I'd say to ask for more help.
I kept trying to do things on my own.
You spend more time on the internet
or real life? Definitely real life,
but often in front of a screen
code. Do you have any pets? No.
What's something you've
learned in the past month?
What it's like to release a big project?
Do you like spicy food sometimes.
What's a movie that made you cry?
The end of the Lord of the rings.
If you were in the world,
what is one law?
I think freedom of the press is great
and there should be more of that.
Do you think will solve
intelligence in your lifetime?
I think we'll probably build
systems as capable as humans,
but we won't understand how they work yet.
Who is one person you looked
up to when you were in college?
Not to own all of us.
She was my mentor for my master's thesis.
She was combining computer science and
neuroscience in the way that I was really
excited by. What deep learning
library do you use the most?
We now use tensor flow and I've
used more theone no, in the past,
Andrew on one said machine learning
is like the new electricity.
Do you agree yet?
But maybe in the future if you
were to start from scratch today,
what is the learning resource you would
use to learn machine learning with a
good book like bishops book,
but then actually trying to
implement the stuff yourself.
Don't just read it and bring it down.
Bring in three. Really actually try it.
What is one career goal you
have lead a big project Sunday.
What's more interesting?
The brain or the universe or the
brain is part of the universe,
but I do think it's pretty interesting
part. If you could be a superhero,
who would it be?
A lot of people say that the thing about
Batman that's cool is that he doesn't
have any like super powers or magical
abilities. I kind of like that.
What's your spirit animal? Uh, save
that I'm, you know, I'm really friendly.
I like get along well with people.
Maybe my spirit animal head Louse.
Do you think one shot learning will
gain momentum? It kind of has to.
If we're going to really get
somewhere with intelligence,
we have to be able to learn from less
data. Would you ever go to Coachella? No.
Instagram or vine Graham Mac
books or Microsoft surfaces books,
but I get a surface is not
bad. Pen or pencil. Pencil.
Would you ever wear the Iwatch? I try
anything once. All right, Catherine,
that's it for my 67 questions. Thanks
so much for answering those. Awesome.
All right.
Have a good one.